The Bachelor franchise has been serving
North American women a slightly
problematic view of dating for over a
decade you know a single man or woman is
surrounded by a room of eligible
Partners cue the gossip tears cat bites
and drama and while the show is being
criticized for reinforcing White
Privilege ageism and problematic dating
tropes today we're of course going to be
zoning in in the lack of body diversity
and the role of upholding body standards
in the media not to mention we'll be
doing a deep dive into how these ladies
eat to prep for the show hey everyone
I'm Abby sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
in today's video we're going to be
unpacking the body exclusive world of
the bachelor and bachelorette But first
you can pause the screen or look at my
description to check out my general
disclaimer we will be talking about
dieting behaviors so please feel free to
skip this video if it's not supportive
to your journey also know that there's
10 years of back Bachelor footage that
we had to go through so please don't
come at me if I miss something in our
research we really do the best that we
can here without having to like write a
dissertation also I'm not getting on The
Bachelor in general I love that show too
but that doesn't mean there's not room
to improve also if you're new here folks
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel ring that Bell so you never miss
out on an episode and follow me on Tick
Tock and Instagram at Abby's kitchen
okay I need to jump in here folks to
tell you about the product that is
literally changed my life okay so maybe
I'm being a little bit dramatic but I
have never been more excited and
passionate about a brand that I've
partnered with let's talk about
zebiotics so I'm not really a huge
Drinker mainly because it hits me super
hard and even after one glass of wine I
am like a shell of myself the next day
without fail alcohol interrupts my sleep
and it flares up my IBS so it's a real
risk benefit analysis if I decide to
imbibe but this sebiotics probiotic
drink has been a game changer ask
literally any of our friends and family
that we go to dinner with we do not
leave the house without our zebiotics
like I have literally turned everyone I
know onto this stuff because we are all
just too old to Rally after a night out
of drinking the way it works is that you
drink a bottle of zebiotics before you
have an alcoholic drink and the
probiotic produces a unique enzyme like
the one that your liver naturally uses
to break down the byproduct responsible
for that not so fun morning this is
absolutely not an invitation to binge
drink alcohol is still not a health food
and should be treated as a substance to
be enjoyed in moderation as I mentioned
over consumption can lead to poor sleep
digestive issues liver damage and
probably a lot of bad decisions but if I
take my sebiotic and stick to a modest
one or two drinks Max on occasion I wake
up feeling amazing and I'm like way more
likely to play with my kids in the
morning rather than and putting them in
front of cocoa melon as I come to like I
said everyone in my immediate circle is
completely obsessed I don't think I will
ever have a drink without my zbiotics
again like my husband and I cheers with
our little zebiotics bottles on the way
to dinner every single weekend it's
super cute so if you want to give
zebiotics a try go to zebiotics.com Abby
sharp and use my promo code Abby sharp
to get 15 off of your first order they
also offer full back money guarantee if
you're not fully satisfied with your
purchase but honestly if anything you'll
be disappointed that you didn't buy more
trust me I am well stocked all right
let's lay down some cold hard facts
after 44 seasons of The Bachelor and The
Bachelorette there have only been two I
repeat two plus size contestants one
have said contestants was former pro
Surfer turned model Bo Stanley who was
cast in 2015 as a plus size contestant
you probably don't remember her of
course because she was cut the very
first week leading viewers to question
if she was there simply to fill the
token big girl roll whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa we gotta stop for a hot minute
here because
can we talk about the fact that the
bachelor franchise and the surfing
Community considers this to be a plus
size large bodied woman I'm confused
like this looks like a perfectly healthy
and athletic woman's body who is likely
far smaller than the average woman who
is at home watching the show having said
that I'm really not surprised that this
is the biggest that the show could
tolerate considering the open distaste
of former host Chris Harrison for larger
folks on TV when asked if he had
considered including a larger body
contestant he said no because that's not
attractive and TV is a visual medium
advertisers need to buy the show so I
need to put on people that others want
to watch I don't know why it's so hard
to believe that people might want to
watch women who they can see themselves
in and not just like another fantasy
with which they cannot relate but I
digress it would seem that Beau was a
real anomaly and even get heading to
episode one since the casting calls
appear to be grossly physically skewed
one applicant Caroline cron recounted
her experience auditioning for the show
while it seemed like she was ready to be
casted she was suddenly ghosted after
her video call with producers where she
was asked to stand turn around and
display her body in various poses and
angles FY I Caroline is a size six to
eight allegedly which is still way below
the American average of size 16 to 18.
and well sure the producers may have
decided to just go in a different
direction as they often say in the
casting World Caroline's gut suggested
that her body just did not fit the
stereotypical mold that it wouldn't
maintain eyeballs during the bikini clad
hot tub scenes like a thin blonde size
2. and speaking of standard look what's
the point of having a dozen eerily
similar looking women on any given
season of the show tall thin long blonde
hair with classic bouncy curls I mean
gorgeous yes but they're really
comparing Apples to Apples here and
making it really hard to tell Laura B
from Laura S and Laura J I mean I never
thought I would feel bad for the
bachelor but it seems like a kind of
tough job but speaking of tough jobs
let's talk about contestants diets
leading up to their six weeks onset now
obviously I have not taken inventory of
every every single contestant's
pre-filming diet and exercise regimen
but based on something infused I read
there does seem to be a lot of rules and
calorie restriction going on according
to Ashley eyes blog she was eating 1400
calories a day consuming water coffee
two small lunches dinner and a 200
calorie dessert and this seems
relatively benign compared to other
contestants accounts Jennifer saviano
claims she cut out all carbs sugar and
alcohol when prepping for the show while
Emily Minard suggested she basically
lived off salads before they shot and
then there's former contestant turned
Bachelorette turning Dancing with the
Stars cast member Caitlin Bristow she
was already personal trainer who worked
out every day but she even added in an
additional daily spin class to her
already rather active lifestyle to
prepare and I don't know maybe this
seems completely normal and expected for
women who are about to be on TV I guess
I'm not that surprised myself
considering that the women are somehow
expected to go on multiple fancy dinner
dates with the wine and Cocktails of
flowing and then still a piece the
producers in their bikini six weeks in
it's just kind of a shame that these
thin already fit women are trying to
heavily manipulate their diet and
exercise regimen to perhaps make their
bodies even thinner because let's be
real that first impression is not coming
from the deep conversation on dinner
dates but speaking of those dinner dates
let's talk about the elephant in the
room why are they often shown with food
but not actually eating it I am
apparently not the only person with
these questions as there are countless
Reddit threads analyzing this single
topic according to an interview with
refinery29 and contestant Jacqueline
Schwartz the food at the dinner dates
are just props like it's real food but
it's not meant to be eaten you're not
supposed to eat them why it's they just
we're at a restaurant they just made
this food when we get back to the beach
and I tell everyone you ate the date
food they're gonna give you so much
you're not supposed to eat the Deep food
the contestants end up eating before
their staged dates because when you're
eating I guess you're not talking and as
she said no one likes to see you stuff
your face am I the only one who does
like seeing real interactions it feels
even a bit triggering to me to see a
woman sit on a date with her food in
front of her and not even take a single
bite because I feel that it reinforces
the cool girl Trope now we discussed
this in my video right here in detail
but in short the cool girl is the girl
who appears to eat like the guys but
somehow maintains a figure as if she
only eats salad there are lots of
examples of this in reality TV where we
see thin beautiful women interacting
with so-called junk food possibly as a
way to perform intuitive eating and
thwart any assorted eating rumors think
the Kardashians pushing around pasta on
their plate but the camera kind of cuts
away before they ever take a bite or in
selling sunset where the fries or the
cupcakes are ordered but sit untouched
if you want to hold video on this food
porn filled intuitive eating performance
phenomenon let me know below but in the
case of the bachelor it seems that this
no eating at dinner dates is some kind
of production rule at least that's what
the contestants themselves suggest
regardless of the intention I do still
worry that the lack of actual eating and
eating scenarios like dinner sends a
strong message to young women to try to
not eat especially in the presence of a
desirable handsome man so listen I have
lots of thoughts about how the media
portrays eligible and worthy singles if
they want to find true love like I'm
pretty sure there's a whole other game
show love is blind that attempted to
like thwart the obsession with
Aesthetics but we generally all know how
that ended up too bachelor Nation fans
have been calling for more body
inclusivity on the show for ages and
while the producers May believe that
slim white blonde women is really all
that people want to see they have to
understand that they shape this
preference when it's all we see it's all
we want the media will need to make a
direct and deliberate shift towards body
inclusivity and general diversity if we
want to see a shift in what people want
this might be a really long journey but
I still think it's one worth pushing for
and on that note that's all that I have
for you guys today I would love to hear
your thoughts on body inclusivity on
shows like The Bachelor and other dating
shows also if you like this video be
sure to give it the thumbs up subscribe
to the channel and I'll see you next
time on Abby's kitchen bye
foreign
[Music]